[Musique]
tempi bangolo ouais ses deux potes ils
font du camping est pris à trois heures
du matin il ya tout qui trempe dans
l'attenté un mec il se réveille il dit à
son pote m'a tant tu fais quoi là vélo
dit libé je me branle et son pote les
bêtes les gentils qui prend ta [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi les lignes annoncées deux buts
qu'on lâche mais la différence entre les
épinards et la sodomie nom qui bafouille
a pas de différence je peux rajouter
tous les beurs que tu veux les enfants
n'aiment pas ça
[Rires]
ah la la
je me désolidarise de laurent baffie
même si c'est un ami mais voilà dans
celle là non ça lâche l'acceptent pas 26
vieille traverse la forêt la nuit ouais
et tient une enfant de non non non non
et la fille était dit j'ai peur j'ai
peur et le privé fait moi tout à l'heure
au retour quand je serai tout seul tu
crois que j'aurais pas peur aux
discussions climatiques
une autre tout de suite pour vous
rattraper avant le vespa valeurs listées
dans l'avion mémoire sans rigoler longue
alors allez-y celle que tu es rouler en
plus alors à l'essai dans l'avion et de
paix n'ayant qu'une - mesures extrêmes
c'est pareil insultes non mais moi oui
c'est vrai problème et on n'a pas marché
contre toi détenteurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cherry prends-moi prends moi j'ai envie
de toi prends moi il dit ça va pas tu es
folle on est dans l'avion il ya plein de
gens maintenant c'est la nuit tout le
monde dort prends-moi prends moi
maintenant je te dis c'est impossible
les gens dorment tu veux je te le prouve
isla elle écrit est ce que quelqu'un
aurait un stylo personne est bon je suis
toi prends moi l'autre il prend le
déclin et toute la vie au petit matin et
l'hôtesse de l'air qui fait sa tournée à
une petite vieille qui grelottent de
froid fait madame vous avez froid a dit
oui j'ai froid mais pourquoi vous n'avez
pas demandé une couverture fait une
couverture
il ya un mec qui il a demandé un crayon
il sait pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
deux copains qui disent qu parce qu'elle
elle est mignonne c'est pour me
rattraper un peu des autres est bien de
copains à discuter y en a un qui dit
hier il m'est arrivé un truc incroyable
je faisais mon footing le long la voie
ferrée comme tous les jours et là je
vois attaché sur la voie ferrée une
fille sublime un canon une beauté
qu'est-ce que je fais là des tâches et
là je suis un héros je l'a ramené à la
maison je les [ __ ] toute la nuit dans
tous les sens sont toutes les positions
sont peu du 10 mai est à sucer voter non
c'est qu'on n'y avait pas la tête